comedian Charlie Murphy dead at 57  et can confirm Charlie died Wednesday  morning at New York Presbyterian  Hospital his manager says Charlie died  of leukemia and that his death was  unexpected one of the comedians last  tweets posted just hours before he died  one to sleep on release the past to rest  as deeply as possible Charlie was the  older brother of Eddie Murphy but over  the years found his own fame as a  stand-up comedian and recently toured  with Cedric the Entertainer and George  Lopez on the comedy get down tour but  perhaps one of his most memorable  appearances was on the Dave Chappelle  show recreating the night he met Rick  James time and will he's coming for his  King Charlie survived by his three  children  [Music]  you